this
is star talk cosmic queries edition i'm
your host
neil degrass tyson your personal
astrophysicist
and today's topic is
you know we had to get there we had you
know everybody's got to do it
everybody's gotta like gotta do it
sharks
we are sharking today and i've got as my
co-host
jordan clepper jordan neil excited to be
sharking with you
okay love you man we love you man this
is we're gonna talk about sharks today
we're gonna do our shows but neither you
nor i have
any expertise in this at all we know
nothing about sharks neither between
us who knows i just know they have teeth
that's all i need to know they're big
and they're hungry spoiler alert you're
ruining this for me
so we we've got a special guest jasmine
graham jasmine welcome to star talk
hello thanks for having me yeah so you
have you had
i didn't know you could you could do
this you're like you're
you your degrees are in biology marine
biology and you
you specialize in sharks this is a thing
it is a thing that's a thing and you've
got a
uh your project coordinator for mars
side lace uh what is that what is that
mars silence i see mars
but that's i don't think that's why what
you got there no not that mars not that
large
marshmallows that's a whole acronym it
is an acronym
it has a long name marine science
laboratory alliance center of excellence
um which i spent the first week of my
job trying to
say without stumbling um but we
are a program that's geared towards
increasing
minority participation in marine science
okay cool and so you're also co-founder
of
miss miss minorities minorities in
shark science yes so um that is
is also a program that's that's geared
towards supporting
um minority students specifically women
of color in shark science
so it's a little more um specific than
my mars highlights project but
i don't mean to sound you know narrow
but that's got to be a hard sell to go
up to the hood and say
hey everybody let's go
let's go find sharks right is this how
does that
work are there is there enough curiosity
like if i'm growing up in the hood
and i'm not thinking about sharks do you
have to overcome that
um so to some extent so so i think what
happens for a lot of people
is they bring up this idea of of sharks
in the ocean at first and then people in
their community are like
then they feel self-conscious and
they're like i mean whenever i told my
family i was going to go
study sharks
you're going to get it because they
don't even get in the ocean um
they fish but i mean they fish to eat
they're not trying to play around with
them and figure out what they're doing
uh so i think the first time that i
asked like what do sharks do
or sorry what did fish do when they're
now on our plate people were like who
cares
yeah yeah yeah if you're gonna be tasty
i don't need to know what you do in the
ocean
[Laughter]
wow so uh very cool so so
so jordan you collected questions from
our fan base got plenty
people are excited to talk about sharks
you know and so sharks spilled over
out of the other places into star talk
we had to go there
all right so jordan give it to me what
do you have let's jump right in with uh
bike and bird patreon subscriber uh he's
got a question
how affected if at all will sharks be
affected by climate change and what
temperatures do the waters have to stay
for them to remain
comfortable oh i love that question yeah
yeah so what's going on there jasmine
so that's a that's a really great
question and something that a lot of
researchers are are interested in
figuring out
um so sharks can't maintain
their own body temperature so unlike us
where we
run the same temperature unless we have
a fever they can't do that so
they are greatly affected by their
environments
and so things like climate change are
things that are definitely going to be
affecting sharks we don't know
how much we don't know at what point it
becomes something that they can't deal
with anymore
um as far as what's the ideal
temperature that varies with sharks so
so some sharks uh i live at
really um cold i mean for a shark
cold temperatures and then some are like
in the tropics so
um it depends and there's a specific
ideal temperature for every
species of sharks so researchers are
really focused on
the individual species and how they're
going to be affected and then another
important thing is their habitat so
there's a lot of sharks especially the
small coastal sharks that depend on
things like mangroves and
reefs and sea grass and so when those
stars go away
the little sharks they just bite off a
limb or a few fingers right the little
sharks
the little sharks the little sharks are
just swimming around
living life we don't have to have
nightmares about the little sharks
that's what i'm wondering i just wanted
to know big ones we have to worry about
yeah i just want to know when do you
need the bigger boat right
so yeah yeah the the most most sharks
are going to be
like so small you're not even like
thinking about them um so they're just
swimming around
of course the really big ones are the
ones that get all the attention the
great whites and the tiger sharks and
they are they are above average size
most sharks are just like hanging out at
like
four or five feet long and they're just
chilling
most the sharks that you're gonna
encounter like going to the beach and
stuff like that you probably have a
shark within
100 yards of you at all times but it's
probably like two feet long
now you tell me this but so the do the
little sharks just bite off your finger
that's all
the little sharks just like swim around
and usually they
get scared really easily so if you make
any sort of movement they're gonna be
like oh my goodness that is a big
animal and i don't know what that is run
away i mean i'm even afraid
do they brush against your thigh that
frightens me
i mean yes if you're in their way and
they're swimming yeah they'll bump into
you
these stories are frightening they're
all frightening
i guarantee you jordan that shark that
touched you
is freaking out like oh my god i touched
a thing and i don't know what that is
you're both freaking out everybody's
freaking out just let it happen
it sounds like high school you know we
don't know what the boundaries are
somebody touches somebody else you're
freaking out internally it's more about
what's going on inside than anywhere
else
so so jasmine let me hypothesize
something i didn't know sharks were very
sensitive to their
environmental temp you know the water
temperature so if that's the case
and you have global warming the water
that's the water temperatures rise
they might have to swim to a lower depth
where it's cooler than they previously
had been and that would change
the food available to them is this a
possible
scenario in a like a climate change
future for sharks
yeah that's that's definitely a possible
scenario and and you know if your prey
moves
you got to move like if you're eating
fish and all the fish swim over here
and you can't follow them that's a
problem that's the end of you yeah
that's right right darwin fixes that
immediately right
right very cool all right jordan that
was actually the uh
that was the first rough draft of the
jaws screenplay
it doesn't end with a gunshot it ends
with the slow building of temperature
change and the inability to regulate
body temperature it was about a seven
hour film
and they had to evolve the sharks so
that it fed at a different depth right
it took a while it's hard to tell that
in any kind of efficient way so they're
like you know what screw it let's have
them
shoot some of some kind of canister in
his mouth
i got a question here from another
patreon subscriber brian
flowers my girlfriend laura would like
to know
with so much of the ocean unexplored can
it be said
definitively that the megalodon is
extinct when tooth specimens not
matching their extinction dates have
been found tell me about the megalodon
there's a movie right there is there is
a movie
called the meg which is a which is an
interesting experience
i knew that we were going to be in for a
wild ride when the poster came out and
the megalodon had like 13 gill slips and
like
that is like twice as many guild slips
as this thing should have
but um yeah so a lot of people ask that
i'm sure wait i'm sure jordan thought
the same thing when he i was like you
know what i
i'm i'm all in but this doesn't feel at
all
the research said i'm gone usually the
authenticity just went out the door
statham is usually so good with
authenticity
yeah so yeah the a lot of people ask
that
of like well how do you know okay first
of all
they were ginormous just like ginormous
and it's not like they were
living in the deep ocean that that was
not the case it's not like oh
they could be down deep in marianas
trench and we could drill them up
actually no
they didn't live that deep that's not a
thing that was happening also
the the biggest way that you can tell is
by the size of our whales
so whales are really big now whales
didn't always used to be big they used
to be small and fast and the reason why
they were small and fast was to avoid
being eaten
by the megalodon so that was their main
like defense against getting eaten by a
megalogon was like
all right this thing is really big i
just got to be really fast so they would
be
really small and really fast and then
megalodon
went extinct and then was the rise of
the great white shark so now we have a
shark that's much smaller
and much faster so then the whale's
strategy
kind of changed a little bit so they
actually evolved to be so big
that it would be a hassle for the great
whites to try and eat them
so if they were all super big and slow
during the time megalodon they would
have 100 percent
gotten taken out like megalodon would
have been like ah a sperm well this is
just a light snack
okay so so what you're saying is they
weren't bottom dwellers so they you
would see them
you would see that you can't hide a huge
animal yeah and their prey
would you that's interesting because
one way to know about whether an animal
exists is whether it's prey is rampant
in an area
and then you say well it can't be that
many foxes if you see many rabbits
right that's a fair this is a fair
evolutionary statement to make i guess
yeah or ecological statement to make
yeah things co-evolve together and
and you know whenever the thing that
they're trying to avoid
goes extinct they're like woohoo
free-for-all we can get as big as we
want now
well i gotta i gotta defend the movie
one last chance here so if the megalodon
is extinct
and gills are not made of fossilizable
tissue
how do you know they didn't have 13
slits
so that i am i good there jordan jordan
on this yeah i think this is this is you
you said you came into this saying you
didn't know about sharks but you were
this is a
this is a slap
fossilized so so cartilage doesn't
fossilize nearly as well as bone
um but you know cartilage does fossilize
and
and we have a lot of scientists not me
it's not my field of expertise but
a lot of scientists do a lot of work on
reconstructing
from what little evidence that we do
have
um so yeah we don't have a lot of of
evidence of megalodon but we do have all
of their relatives and none of their
relatives have 13 bill slips so
it is highly probable that that they
didn't have 13 gill slips either even
though we don't have
you know all of the fossils and
everything like that
and we're doing a lot of estimating and
guesstimating um
so can i say 100 that they didn't have
13 gill slips
no i cannot but the chances of sharks
going from 13 gill slits to five
um that's that would be a lot of changes
that would need to
i got you okay that's fair very fair
fairly argued there i think
it's like i don't know nail push back on
that science
[Laughter]
if you don't know how i debate my weird
uncle if you're using my weird uncle to
date whether or not i'm going to be
a 350 pound conservative from indiana
it's just not gonna match
well that's what happens because you
know where the anthropologists they find
the one skeletal remains
and then everything about the entire
species is anchored to that
so if they found your uncle and that was
the representative human of all humans
you know
uh are you saying we'd have issues
that's we would have issues as long as
they don't go looking in suburban
indiana
then he's not going to be the original
man the fossilized version of the
original man
so so a variant on this is do you
portray your dragons
with four limbs plus two wings
or lettuce one two three four appendages
plus two wings
or are the front limbs the wings
okay and so uh in
game of thrones the dragons the front
lin the front limbs were the
wings as is true with bats and any other
sort of vertebrate that flies so you
can't just
throw in another pair of appendages and
in the model that we have here on earth
so is that a fair analogy jasmine do you
think
yeah definitely i mean you have to use
what information you have
and yeah we're drawing dinosaurs and
and prehistoric creatures and stuff to
the best of our abilities and sure we
get things wrong but we do have a
blueprint
you know they didn't totally change
shape that quickly that's not how
evolution happens you don't go like
oh and then suddenly there was an
individual born that had an extra pair
of limbs and then they
procreated with another individual that
had an extra pair of limbs and suddenly
everyone had
decided that's very bio 101 right there
evolution 101. all right jordan what
else you got
i got a another patreon subscriber joy
panero denise
considering mammals returned to the
ocean and dominate it
have sharks reached an intelligence
plateau would climate change
ironically provide an opportunity for
sharks to adapt and become
more intelligent ooh i like that first
jasmine said it straight the mammals
in the ocean did not evolve there
is that correct i mean they were mammals
on land and returned
to the water yes that is crazy
yeah there's a lot of back and forth so
like so we have
life starting in an aquatic setting then
there was some that went to land and
they did all this evolution on land and
then they were like you know what
land is like ah i'm just gonna go back
land is overrated
like tulum you know like it was cool for
a little while but i'm coming in a
little while
they went back into the ocean which is
weird because the ocean can kill us
as humans right you don't this is not a
first thought
and so for some species to have that
thought they've got to have some pretty
good adaptable
elements to them yeah so you i mean you
have
especially where you had situations
where there were
major predators on land and they
couldn't go in the water so
why don't you just run into the water
and the predator can't get you and then
you know you have some individuals that
are born with some special adaptations
that help them
in the water and then they're more
successful because they can hang out in
the water and avoid the predators and
then that just kind of builds and builds
and builds and builds and builds
so you have this this situation where
you're like there are lots of dangerous
things on land that are trying to eat me
wouldn't it be
great if i didn't have to contend with
those individuals
and so that's kind of how this
directional shift happens
and then you also have things like um
you know big asteroids and stuff just
like decimating the air
quality and if you were in the water you
didn't breathe air you're like haha
joke's on you that's not a problem for
me
that's cold you're gonna carry on like
that that ain't right
um also it seems to me that a lot of the
the aquatic mammals have a
very significant fat layer on their
bodies
so if you were sort of fatter plus fat
is more buoyant than muscles so if you
were a
fatter mammal you could survive
lower temperatures in the water relative
to other mammals and you wouldn't have
to come out as soon so i see how this
could
lead lead to this so so yeah so in the
future
if our only salvation is the ocean the
skinny people all die
what oh no
you're a crazy uncle jordan
i was going to say it as you were saying
that i was like oh
the larger folks survive longer uh he
might do okay in indiana
we got to take a quick break but when we
come back more with jasmine graham we're
talking about
sharks past present and future on star
talk
we're back star talk my co-host jordan
clapper jordan
neil sharks i'm you know we started this
and
we both agreed that we were walking into
this with a certain amount of ignorance
and i'd like to think
uh i've learned nothing up to this point
but that's but that's not because the
information isn't good it's just it's
really hard to get through me right now
i'm still thinking about the logistics
of the movie the meg but i'm gonna get
it
okay so you just confessed the density
of your skull
to both of us oh no it's
i was i wasn't supposed to tell anybody
so jasmine you
um you have a master's degree in
biological sciences
of florida state university florida
there's a lot of marine science in
florida
colleges isn't that right there is i
mean we're a peninsula we got a lot of
ocean
got a lot of ocean plus you're going to
be gone in the global warming
oh yeah miami is gone yeah just sorry
miami
florida like the average sea level in
florida is like an inch
still lucky high tides don't take them
out every single time
colleges in florida having to do with
climate change and also
the way we fund upper education uh not
something to invest in
not the best combination there so how
long have you been interested in sharks
uh since my freshman year of college
okay so what did you watch shark week or
something on discover channel or
something
i did watch shark week when i was a kid
and
um yeah we watched a lot of discovery
channel um
but i didn't think about sharks
really like you study them that was not
a thought that crossed my mind
um i actually didn't even know that you
could be a marine biologist as a career
until i was like a junior in high school
and i was like what you could get paid
to do this
yeah and then i went to college and i
i met a professor who did shark science
and
did the evolution of study the evolution
of sharks and he was just super excited
about sharks and then i just got excited
by osmosis and i was like sure
i'll just come work on sharks and then
the more i got into it the more i was
like whoa
sharks are really really cool
sharks forever excellent excellent and
because they're so different from other
uh marine species just everything i read
they don't have bones right they just
have cartilage is that right
just cartilage so so their teeth are
stronger than their scaffolding
which is important if you're a predator
like that's important
you got to be flexible and nimble to
chase things and you got to have strong
teeth to eat them
it's like it's a perfect design perfect
killing machine
all right jordan you got more questions
for us i do we've got a question
here uh from facebook this is from kevin
hardy
why are surfboards and wetsuits painted
black to make humans look like seal food
to sharks
why don't we use high contrast zebra
prints to break up the silhouette
ooh so so wait just to understand
if you look up from below the the
shadowing of the surfboard it looks like
a seal
i didn't know i didn't know that that's
what this implies okay so jasmine
yeah so what the surfer community they
almost take pride when they show you
their shark
teeth scars right that they survived it
what what
what's your responsibility to them so
yeah so if they you know if a shark is
looking up at them
and they're on the surfboard yeah it
does kind of resemble a seal or
something that is actually shark food
um and and so yeah like with the
with the coloring and the the pattern
and stuff that's not going to really
make
a huge difference because the sharks
aren't really going to be able to tell
that your
zebra print from like if they're looking
up at you
they're just looking at the outline at
the shadow um
so the best thing to do is to try your
best not to look like seal
um so like try not to flail around
and definitely don't surf in areas where
there's high
shark activity um so like if there
is you know some bait balls or something
bait balls are like
huge clouds of fish swimming really fast
in one direction
um they're running away from something
you should probably move
it just be observant take your cues from
other species
and you know if you have any sort of
dead or
decaying animal um around
then yeah don't go so like there's the
movie called the shallows that came out
a while ago
where she's like surfing by this big
decaying whale
thing and i'm like first of all why
like that there is a large decaying
animal
just like a smorgasbord for sharks and
you're like i'm gonna go surf right here
and then i'm gonna get knocked off my
board and i'm gonna climb
on the dead whale why is that a decision
that you made like
just stay away from things that sharks
eat so you don't get confused with food
because you know usually you have shark
bites and for the shark it's like
i wonder what this was like one of this
is edible chomp ew
nope that's not what i thought it was
swim away but like that little chomp is
like well there goes your leg
so you don't want to even be in a
situation
where the shark is confused and needs to
check you out
just like you know keep keep your
distance away from things
like huge bait balls or like where
people are fishing
or dead decaying animals and just
if you if you have a lifeguard or
someone tell you like hey
there are sharks mating in this area i
don't think it's a good idea for you to
go surfing don't say like this is
america and do what i want
you can but that might not end well
so as long as americans are just logical
and think through things we'll be fine
i don't have a lot of faith
[Laughter]
so jordan give me some more uh you know
what we're gonna we're gonna stay on
this movie inspired
idea somebody really wants to know
cameron jefferson from facebook
if a tornado started over a school of
sharks what would really happen
bit i don't know what you're talking
about i'm sorry
to say no no what jasmine and i don't
know what they're actually asking about
neil
you know neil neil admit it you and i
have talked offline about sharknado for
hours
no we have not your favorite movie you
have posters up right now people can see
your office
it's nothing but sharknado posters all
right jasmine what
what's what's up with that so as
glorious as it would be
for an entire school of sharks to be
lifted up in a tornado and just like
plopped in another location uh no
sorry that's not how that works but it
would be
so cool and like you know but jasmine
you're undermining the main premise of
that movie series it's still
a great movie series because it's
utterly ridiculous and super
entertaining and don't let that stop you
from enjoying shark data like
don't let it stop you it's funny it
doesn't claim to be accurate that's not
what it's claiming to do
it's claiming to entertain and it
succeeds i thought i thought it was
based on a true story
that's my bad yeah the great sharknado
of 1917.
so jordan i don't you guys know i had a
cameo in
sharknado 6. i didn't know that you were
attract nato 6
yes at a cameo and i was overlooked by
the academy
i thought you know i i thought that
performance
was totally worthy of some kind of award
but
do you remember your line from
sharknado6 uh
no i played merlin
and because the in sharknado 6
i bet you didn't know there were five
other sharks yeah i'm gonna say that was
there's multiple surprising pieces of
information
jasmine did you know there were six i
knew there was a lot and i didn't know
the number
yeah yeah so in this one the tornado
opens a portal
through the space-time continuum and
goes back to
two medieval days and in so doing
shark dna merges with dragon dna
so you have shark dragon nato's
and i'm in the medieval times dark ages
really and
i'm i play merlin and i do actual
science but people think it's magic
that's a pretty good call that's what i
thought that's what i thought
i could i could do that i could do that
and i think i ride one of these shark
dragons
in the tornado i was on a green screen
you know rocking pony
um but yeah but it was a question
how many limbs did this dragon show
but jasmine i i'm very proud of you and
delighted to hear
that you were entertained by this movie
series without being distracted by
the little bit of science that got wrong
so jordan give me some more let's head
to facebook we got manuel
arguello he asks what innovation used
today can we attribute to research done
with sharks
actually i like this but neil we've
talked in the past about
our love of space our love of nasa and
all of the fun innovations that come
uh from focused on trying to to get to
places like the moon
right you did a whole you did a whole
special when you visited uh
nasa headquarters we did yes
headquarters one of these centers yeah
yeah we talked all about that it's like
even those who are frustrated about our
our attempts to get back to the moon or
to mars it's the byproduct of that kind
of
ingenuity is bad yes so jasmine
is can you justify what you do
that's that's the more direct way
just i get that all the time so let me
now i get to dish it out to you
hi jasmine what good is it for the rest
of us so there's there's a lot of
materials that come from sharks that
people use and things like lotions and
medicines
and and makeup and stuff like that
there's
a compound that's found in their livers
which helps them be
buoyant um that people use on a lot of
different things
um also a lot of um wait i didn't know
sharks wore makeup
they they don't but people do and
yes out there that are right now
looking at your lotions and being like
it doesn't say anything about sharks
um it usually calls it like squalene
or squala something that is
that is shark liver just so you shark
extract
whatever you're putting that on your
face okay
um there's also been a lot of
engineering feats so that have been
based off of the
hydrodynamics of sharks because you know
they've spent millions of years evolving
they're super speedy they cut through
the water super fast
um so a lot of that engineering
principles when they're designing
underwater vehicles and things like that
comes from
you looking at the structure that
evolution has already provided as the
winning structure
which is the sharks i thought i
remembered wasn't there some bathing
suits in the olympics that people wore
that
i remembering this correctly that was
inspired by
shark yeah so they had identical
or things like tentacles which are these
modified scales that sharks have
they kind of look more like teeth
actually um
and um here's another phrase that i can
drop jordan as someone that's gotten
shark bird a lot
um it really hurts whenever they rub
against you
um they are sharp they are sharp little
things
um and yeah shark burn is a thing if a
shark rubs against you
uh okay but wait wait so but why would
you make a swimsuit out of that
that resembles that because it helps
them
cut through the water really quickly it
cuts down on drag and friction as
they're moving through the water oh
okay you could what i know i get it now
because what you can have
things that look like they would
interfere with what they do is they
break up turbulence
and force much more laminar flow where
you can go through okay i'm with you on
that very interesting
and uh something else about the teeth
did we anything we can learn about the
fact that they have multiple teeth
multiple generations of teeth yes they
have rows of teeth
um so basically their teeth are just
always
good to go so you know you chip their
teeth i mean they're
they're eating things that are really
tough and they're tearing at
stuff and they're like oh i chipped a
tooth or my tooth fell out whatever
there's another one back here and it's
just like whoop
um and so they're they just always have
fresh teeth it's like
whenever you have knives your knives get
dull and you have to like re-sharpen
them how cool would it be if like you
used your knife and it got dull and
you're like it's fine i got another
knife right here it's like
super useful
so it's because sharks are so different
from all other
aquatic fishes that it gives us these
sort of unique
interesting questions and solutions
regarding them is that a fair
characterization yeah and i mean they do
lots of really cool things like they
heal
super quickly um which is something that
we as humans are like hey how do they do
that that might be something that's
useful how are they healing themselves
maybe we can use that in medicine and
things like that
um there's a lot of diseases that they
don't get that we are
interested in researching and trying to
figure out what
makes them resistant to those types of
things and and can we recreate that and
use it in
human medicine and stuff like that so
there's a lot of things whenever you
have something
that has been evolving for so long it's
like
why reinvent the wheel nature already
figured out what works
like humans aren't going to do any
better we should just like borrow what
nature already figured out
we could figure out a way to make it
useful to humans okay so what's left
unsaid here jordan
is to get all of these products and to
study the shark in this way
you have to kill the shark sometimes you
do yeah
yeah yeah it's not like we're studying
primate
livers and put making lotion out of it
there would be objections to that
so i think the since sharks like to eat
us we don't have any problems killing
them
for whatever purpose that can serve us
in return
it's unspoken but that's basically true
we've set up we've set up a way in which
it's fun to watch the gladiatorial
nature of man versus sharks so therefore
we get good lipstick out of it
so yeah unfortunately there are a lot of
sharks that are killed like 100 million
a year and that's why we're doing a lot
of things for conservation of like all
right guys we're killing sharks
way faster than they can replace
themselves because they they grow slowly
they take a long time to mature
um and so we don't want to to take them
out
faster than they can replace themselves
so there's all kinds of
conservation and stuff that goes into
that where we're moderate monitoring
the stocks and we're doing things like
assessing
their their population sizes we are
trying to put regulations in place
of like there's not a lot of these types
of sharks left you can't fish for these
types of sharks
um so we're definitely moving a lot into
the regulation but i think a lot of it
is like what you're saying
we have this negative perception of
sharks
which is unwarranted because they're
just living their lives
um and we therefore feel like we can do
whatever we want to the sharks versus
like a dolphin that's like
everyone thinks it's all cute and
whatever but really they're like
the same one's a mammal one's a fish but
they are
both apex predators they both have sharp
teeth they both are
really good at what they're doing but
we've decided that dolphins are cute and
sharks are scary so we can kill sharks
right so if you if you drag a dead shark
into the onto the beach and say look
what i killed on my boat
wow that's cool if you dragged a dead
dolphin say look what i killed
people would ostracize you yeah so this
is a speciesist
what's the word speciesist what's the
word you're a species
species species yeah you're being you're
being specious
yeah yeah definitely so that's why
you're racist you're a species
speciesist we're working so hard to
change the perceptions that people have
of sharks and
and trying to show them like okay
there's a lot of benefits to sharks
especially the ones that are apex
predators they're
maintaining balance in the ecosystems
they're really important
sharks aren't out to get you they're not
like hunting you down
they're not really even worried about
you and yeah
it's just people are really afraid of
getting bit by a shark
um which yeah sucks to get bit by a
shark but the chances of that happening
are very slim
the chance of getting bit by a dog
however are very probable and we bring
them into our houses and we put cute
outfits on them
you're you're going into specious
territory right now you be careful
you be careful well some people like
pitfalls i don't know that's what i'm
saying if you put
people in your house
some people like anacondas you know
that's just what they can't we just all
be
equally afraid of animals at the same
level i'm afraid of sharks i'm afraid of
pit bulls i'm also afraid of dolphins
i'm afraid of cats i could be afraid of
everything on an equal level
yeah you should be concerned about all
animals
all animals have the possibility to
injure you just give them their space
and don't make them happy all right we
got one more segment coming
after this break on star talk
we're back on star talk and where we
left off in this shark edition of cosmic
queries
is jasmine tells us that we shouldn't
kill sharks
unless we want to make lotion out of
them and then it's okay
that is not what chelsea does that's
what i heard i i heard that too
well i heard that i swear that's where
that's what she said no no
just we need to understand how they fit
into the ecosystem
and not be so so uh speciesist about
what animals are cute and which animals
are not
yeah that's really what there's there
are some cute sharks out there everybody
google a picture of an epaulette shark
they're adorable
adorable the word adorable and the word
shark
appeared in the same sense they have
little they have little fins and they
walk they're super cute also bonnet
heads are adorable
they look like they have little bonnets
on their heads take it from jasmine
she has she has picked up and held so
many sharks she's picked up sharks okay
all right all right so let's let's keep
this going neil i got something from
uh facebook joe klopp he wonders given
the fact that sharks are neither born
live
or hatched from what we would normally
refer to as an
egg what does baby shark do do
do do do do do
so i didn't know i didn't know any of
that so could you just catch me up on
this please
i want to i want to clarify something so
so there are
sharks that are born live it's not like
a
placental birth like a like a mammal
um but yes there are sharks that are
born live there are also sharks that
come from eggs
but aren't like chicken eggs they're
like little leathery looking little
pouches that are sometimes called
mermaid purses which is an adorable name
um but yes so baby sharks what do baby
sharks do
they just try to survive because uh
sharks don't have parental care so like
you are born and you are
on your own whether you're born live
or you hatch uh they'll try and um lay
their eggs in a place where they're like
this feels like a good spot
i feel like my kids are gonna have a
chance here and then they're just like
bye kids
um and then the sharks that give live
birth
you know they like pop them out and the
sharks swim away and they're like cool
my work here's done wow so so
so mammals have very few births per
litter
and so how many how many possible sharks
can come out of a one
egg laying session uh so that depends on
the shark
uh so there are some sharks that give
live birth and they only have
um one and um that's usually because
they just the one that develops first
just like eats the risks or it
ingests the rest of them and it's like
cool thanks for the nutrients
jordan did you hear that euphemism it
ingests them
it just doesn't maul them in their sleep
no they're ingested
i get what you're throwing down yeah
okay ingest them
yeah and then there are some there are
some sharks that have very large
litters uh like 20 or more but it kind
of
really just varies between the the
different sharks of how many
they're having um and even within
species there's there's often a range
okay all right so so what so we
in in mammals there's their mammary um
mammary food for them what what's the
first thing a baby shark eats
um so for the ones that are um
cannibalistic they're siblings um for
the ones that are not
and you want us to not be afraid of
sharks
they eat their own siblings yikes
the parents drop them off and they're
like you're good
eat your brother usually usually
if your little brother's annoying just
eat them
[Laughter]
the eating of the siblings usually
happens inside the mom
so if the mom doesn't even see the other
ones that's
worse i don't know something that's
worse that's worse okay
she said wait jordan she said that like
no it's different it happens
inside them it's an entire family
working together
to eat one of them yeah i mean that
that's what happens um and then the rest
of them usually it's yolk
um so they'll they'll have a yolk
attached to them a yolk sac
that's their nutrients um and then once
that's gone
usually they you know they've developed
enough where they can hunt
on their own and so yeah so usually
it's they're either cannibalistic or
they have a yolk
man that's a tough life i'm staying on
land by the way i'm not going to be one
of those that goes back in
yeah it feels much safer here
jordan give me another one yes we have
here from
uh zanzino ferrara from facebook
since we know our moons have influence
on tides in our oceans
there is some kind of influence uh is
there some kind of influence by the moon
and sharks
lives oh interesting uh as in
the zones they choose to live in our
oceans and all the best to you guys i
hope you stay safe
excellent question thank you for that
yeah so jasmine
tell me about the astronomical
influences on shark behavior
yeah so that's something that a lot of
sharks actually
they're we think that their migrations
um are actually triggered by um
moon faces and things like that only if
there's sagittarius
there's a lot of obviously the tides and
the moon are really really connected and
so there's a lot of sharks that move
with the tides
with looking for their prey um so
they'll could it be that because when
when the tide goes out
deep water becomes shallow and certain
fishes become
if not entirely stranded they certainly
can't
escape to safety would a shark risk
getting stranded itself to go on shallow
shallow tide
tidewaters yeah so so sharks go into
shallow areas and and then there are
some sharks that can handle
um lower salinities and so they'll
actually
swim up into the rivers with the with
the tides
and um they get everything that's like
coming in
because they're they're like oh okay the
tide is changing and their their food is
kind of moving with the tides and then
they kind of get funneled into the mouth
of this river because there's only one
way for them to go and then the sharks
will be like
smorgasbord and they just sit there at
the mouth of the river and they're just
like i'm going to eat everything that's
true
so the sharks took astronomy 101 they
know about tides and estuaries
and brackish water versus fresh water
these are intelligent sharks they are
evolving in intelligence the way that
earlier question
had inquired we'll find out you know it
in another million years they'll be
running the world
[Laughter]
this is it's coming right from the
horse's mouth you know neil
now i'm afraid of rivers i thought
rivers were safe now you're telling me
sharks are sneaking up there as well
yeah this is this is a very depressing
session
yeah there are some sharks that can
handle uh lower salinity waters for for
short periods of time
um bull sharks are the the most famous
of these
um they can go up in the river um and
then
they'll come back they have some special
adaptations that help them
maintain balance even when they're in
lower salinity waters which is super
cool
all right time for a few more yep i got
one from twitter
nathan warden how exactly do sharks
smell
blood in the water and what is the real
range of that smell
oh i like that yeah how fast can blood
travel in water anyway
so blood doesn't travel very fast in
water uh so you know how
so so there's this myth but that like oh
you have a drop of blood a shark is
gonna smell it from a mile away
and i'm like that's not how that's not
how molecules
move it has to dissipate it's going to
take a long time to dissipate just like
if you're on one side of the room and
someone farts on the other side
and there's like this wave where
everyone across the room is slowly
smelling it before you get it
in sequence in sequence and you like
you're like oh there's a bad
smell coming but there's no escaping it
because you just see everyone reacting
to it
that's just how smells dissipate in the
air the same thing happens in the water
so it's not like
there's a drop of blood and all of a
sudden a mile away this shark is like
oh there's blood uh no it has to
has to dissipate um and in actuality
um that's way too diluted at that point
a mile away it's gonna be too diluted
for them to actually
detect it the most sensitive sharks
um it would probably be more like a
quarter of a mile
um before it gets to the point where it
would be
too diluted for them to be able to
detect it plus it has to they gotta
be plus if they're ocean currents they
wouldn't be able to smell it up
upstream they've got to be like
downstream from it yeah there's all
sorts of things that need to happen it's
not like oh you have a drop of blood and
suddenly
all of the sharks in the world are just
like descending upon you
also sharks aren't interested in the
smell of human blood because they don't
need humans
like they would they would smell it but
it wouldn't they wouldn't react to it
um now if you have a bunch of fish
bleeding yeah
okay then they're gonna come check it
out but if it's if it's a
human's blood that that's not something
that they're cued into
because that's not what they eat um so
they would yeah they would smell it but
they wouldn't be like oh that smells
delicious
let me go snack that's not gonna be
their reaction
but if i've had like fish oil pills that
morning i cut my finger
on a bud light and i go into the water
how nervous should i be
you should not be nervous do not be
nervous
drink drink and swim away okay you would
be fine
right so just time for like a few more
maybe we can do a lightning round
so let's let's let's try it jordan this
is from uh mike irish 85
on instagram studies have shown that low
frequency sound pollution
possibly have negative effects on animal
animal behavior in the ocean
do sharks show up in these studies and
what are the effects
oh nice one so like the rumble of a
cruise ship
um uh rotors i mean the propeller blades
yeah so so what do we know about that
jasmine yeah there have been studies
where they they've played sounds
underwater um and had
um baited cameras and um
there were less there was less shark
activity around the baited cameras when
there were artificial sounds played
so it does affect them baited you mean
but it's got food for them so they
might want to come to the food so this
is a good experiment to see
if the sound is so bad for them that
they'll forego the food
yeah wow okay but no one cares about the
sharks
so we don't care i care about the sharks
you care okay so no one
except jasmine cares about sharks okay
all right jordan got a good good
quick answer this is from amir john
kerr on instagram are great white sharks
really afraid of dolphins
um it's more like a competition thing
um not necessarily fear just like we're
eating the same things and if you're
here then i have to compete with someone
so i'm gonna go
hunt somewhere where there's not a comp
not anyone competing with me
okay that's good that's that's the smart
thing to do
yeah work smarter not harder that's the
motto of the sharks
okay it's not uh eat your brother if
things uh don't work out
oh man i should not have mentioned that
it's never i mean i'm not gonna shake
that for years
and to be clear that that question was a
gimme that question was about
uh baby shark that was about a
children's cartoon and you were like
you should talk about uh
uh here's another fun one this is from
uh joe placebo
on instagram are the greenland sharks
really over 500 years old and what makes
them different from other sharks
yeah how long do sharks live so yeah
okay so the the green lunch sharks age
is as a topic of discussion among
scientists
uh so people say 400 maybe but like
we're just yeah around there um at least
we've got it
close um so yeah they they live alone
wait wait wait wait we didn't even know
greenland existed
400 no i don't know when it was
discovered but we can't have possibly
had good data
400 years ago to age date a shark
from 400 years ago how how we learn how
do we know this
um yeah so there's there's other ways to
to do dating um
you can do carbon dating you can look at
the calcification on vertebrae
because they'll have rain yeah dead
sharks
you're not they're not asking the sharks
how old they are no right
that was happening the census is hard
enough to get everybody to comply
in america let alone greenland sharks
good luck getting an accurate count
then how many people in the household
well i hate them yeah
yeah do you have any siblings uh that's
a difficult question for me to answer
yeah yeah junior used to live and then
but not anymore
yeah we used to look at the beginning of
the year there was three seconds
whatever happened in june
uh he was my brother now he's just
indigestion
so is it true that sharks just keep
growing their whole lives
they do they have what's called
indeterminate growth which means as long
as they're alive they will keep growing
obviously it slows down when they get
older um but yes they they do keep
growing so the bigger the shark the
older it is
wow so this okay so
but the jury's still out on exactly how
old the greenland sharks might be
yeah but hundreds clear
hundreds yeah damn you know we have we
have some specimens
but like like i said we can't ask ever
we can't ask all the greenland sharks so
whoever you whoever you've sampled
that's like okay we found a greenland
check that this one that's this old but
there could be others that are that are
older that one could be the exception
and not the rule
um so it could it could be jordan's
uncle
yeah going to survive
forever
so we've we've got to actually bring
this to a close let me just offer a
reflection here based on all i've
gleaned
in this conversation jasmine thank you
for these enlightening
points i just wonder if if
if climate change continues and
we keep destroying the whale population
okay whales are not you know i don't
know how much they're coming back
that could take away part of the
what's the term you use for who's at the
top of the food chain you had a great
term for that
apex predator apex predator so
then the shark has there's nothing
topper higher than the shark right then
we go extinct on land and then the shark
figures out
it could come out of the water and go on
land and so if we come back
in you know a million years it won't be
planet of the apes it'd be planet of the
sharks
and the sharks would be like town mayor
and the police and
and and so that somebody needs to write
that story
and in the sixth iteration of it i know
who's going to play merlin
i'll be there if you need it
jasmine graham thank you for this your
first time on star talk i think is it
right
yeah well thank you and sharks are
they're perennially
interesting to so many people myself
included and i think
maybe jordan um so we'll try to have to
get you back on
and because jordan how many questions
did we not ask because we ran out of
time i think there were there were a ton
i got 10 more pages of questions to
pages okay
so we'll hold on to those pages so so
jasmine again you co-founder of
minorities in shark sciences and so
we'll see
see more people of color in a field that
historically we've never
seen anybody of color and you're also
project coordinator
of the marine laboratory and aquarium uh
very cool so you're in it stay with it
stay healthy
and jordan what's your latest project
when you're not interviewing trump
supporters
what do you do next well you know i'm
i'm following the campaign with the
daily show
and i'm about to become a father real
soon so that's why
that's my next big project a first time
father first time dad
oh wow okay so i'm gonna get to know
that baby shark
oh you'll see it i would recommend
not introducing your child to baby shark
you will never hear the end of it
i'm gonna take that that's advice from
an expert i'm gonna take it hi jasmine
delighted to meet you
jordan always good to have you i'm neil
degrasse tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist
signing off as always by getting you to
keep looking
you